-Our next guest is a former
United States Congressman
and currently the Democratic
nominee for governor of Texas.
Please welcome back to the show
Beto O'Rourke, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
It's always lovely to have you
back in New York City.
We talked last time about how
you spent some time in Brooklyn.
You had Busta Rhymes' -- an old
trampoline from Busta Rhymes
on the roof of your apartment,
which is a pretty cool thing.
-Very cool thing.
-Yeah.
-A big memory.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You also drove --
One of your jobs when you were
living in Brooklyn is you
drove around famous artwork?
-I worked for a company called
Hedley's Humpers.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And we would receive
and crate pieces of art
that were bought
by our customers,
and then deliver them
to their homes.
And so, yeah, I would be driving
down the streets of New York
in a box truck
with amazing pieces of art.
One time I was able
to handle a Picasso...
-Wow.
-...if you can believe this.
You know, what am I,
23 years old, and I've got
a Picasso in my hands
delivering for a client.
-I was going to say,
it's a terrible --
Hedley Humpers
is a terrible name,
except I don't think
anyone would ever think
a Picasso would be in a truck...
-Right.
-Like, you would be like,
"Well, that's probably just full
of old pillows or something."
-Right, right, right.
But amazing people
who worked there.
Most of them were artists.
I was not.
One guy -- went on to have a
great career -- named Dave Ford,
who does these amazing
interactive sculptures,
including one that he developed
by putting canvas
down on the floor of the truck
and then hanging drawing
implements from the ceiling,
and it would record
this kind of kinetic map
of our journeys along the way.
And, you know, now you
can't get your hands on them
because they're so valuable.
But amazing experience.
Loved living in New York.
But soon enough, I knew
I needed to be back in Texas.
-Yes.
-Because that's where I'm from.
My family's there.
And I just missed the state,
missed home.
-So, back in Texas,
you're running against
Governor Greg Abbott.
And obviously, you know,
Texas --
He, you know, banned abortion
after six weeks.
And that, I think,
is scary enough,
but he also implemented
this bounty law.
Can you explain
exactly how harrowing
this element of his law is?
-Yeah, so, there's
a law in force right now
that is a six-week abortion ban
with a $10,000 bounty placed
on the back of anyone
who assists any woman
in making her own decision
about her own life,
her own body,
her own health care.
But it's actually worse because
he also signed what is known
as a trigger bill,
which means that if the Supreme
Court overturns Roe v. Wade,
which is likely to happen,
it triggers a total abortion ban
beginning at conception,
with no exception for rape
and no exception for incest.
And that's happening
in a state that leads
much of the developed world in
a crisis of maternal mortality.
It means that our moms and women
are dying faster
than almost anywhere else
because as you close down
all these reproductive
health-care clinics,
not only is it harder
to get an abortion,
it's harder to get
a cervical cancer screening
or to see a family
planning provider
or to get a doctor at all
in the least-insured state
in the country.
So this is deeply,
deeply harmful,
and, frankly, deadly
to the women of Texas.
That's why we've got to win
this race, win political power,
and get the state
back on the right track
so every woman can make her
own decision about her own body,
her own future,
and her own health care.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There is, um --
I think it's so important.
You don't want to get in a
situation where you're always
saying the sky is falling,
and yet, when Donald Trump
appointed these new
Supreme Court justices,
a lot of people said
they're gonna overturn
Roe v. Wade.
So the sky was falling.
So I know I'm putting you
in a tough position,
but what do you think --
It's bad enough
with the abortion ban,
but what do you think
Governor Abbott might do next,
empowered with this ability
to take these steps
that he's already taken?
-I saw a headline today.
You know, some of his colleagues
in the state legislature
are talking about a law
that would stop Texas women
from traveling to other states
to seek their constitutional
right to an abortion.
And this is stuff
that maybe is happening
because of a failure
of imagination on our part.
Like, "There's no way
this is going to happen,"
and it is now happening.
"There's no way
it could get worse,"
but it will,
unless we change course.
The encouraging thing that
I can share with you from Texas
is that the people of Texas
want better.
A majority of us do.
We had a rally on Saturday
in Houston
for reproductive
health-care rights.
5,000 people came out
on three days' notice.
It was the largest reproductive
health-care rally
in the country, and it happened
in the place you'd maybe
least expect it to happen in,
which is Texas.
But I think that reflects
the majority of us there,
who not only want to make sure
that our rights are protected,
but they want us to get focused
on the big things
that we can all
actually agree on,
like the kind of jobs
we want to create,
focusing on our public schools,
getting the backs of our
public-school educators,
expanding Medicaid,
which we haven't done in Texas,
though most of the rest
of the country has,
so that people are
healthy enough and well enough
to live to their full potential.
Those are the things
that we want to do.
The abortion ban,
this crazed focus
on transgender kids
and arresting their parents
for child abuse,
permitless carry,
the failure of the power grid --
that's reflective
of current leadership,
not of the state of Texas.
My job as a candidate
is to go out
and meet the people of Texas
to bring them
into this election.
We do that, and I'm confident
we're gonna win in November.
-Alright. I got
some more questions for you.
We'll be right back with more
from Beto O'Rourke.